Speaker 1: om there.
And we are going to be watching the next 48
hours very, very closely.
Is there a gag order?
Does the fundraising continue?
Do Trump's protesters actually come out and
seem even remotely interested in defending
him, or is it just a couple dozen people at
Mar a Lago?
All of it will be live on our YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook.
And it is going to be quite a couple of days.
Let's talk about Marjorie Taylor GREENE on
60 Minutes.
Dozens of you wrote to me, as many people
wrote to me as the number that protested for
Trump at Mar a Lago.
Dozens, dozens of you wrote to me and said,
David, what is your take about 60 Minutes
interviewing Marjorie Taylor GREENE?
They are platforming a lunatic.
They are pretending as though they're normalizing
the idea of Marjorie Taylor GREENE As someone
who should be in government, It's just a matter
of do we agree about her views rather than
making her out to be the dangerous extremist
who has no business in a position of power.
I tweeted yesterday, I understand the concerns
and I want to see the interview first.
And the reason I said I want to see the interview
first is I've long advocated for something
called responsible platforming.
And by responsible platforming, I mean.
It's not about who you interview.
It's how you interview them.
And so, for example, when I have someone on
the show who is explaining nuclear fission
to us as a subject matter expert, I handled
that interview differently than when I interview
interviewed, for example, white nationalist,
neo-Nazi Richard Spencer.
If I can have Richard Spencer on, I need to
be prepared to make sure that my audience
understands his extremist ideas are dangerous,
that they're bogus, and so on and so forth.
I think people get this.
The point is the interviews appropriateness
is evaluated based on how the interview was
handled.
Speaker 2: And it wasn't.
Speaker 1: Handled the best by Lesley Stahl,
but it wasn't the end of the world.
Overall, I don't like that.
I think the interview did normalize.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE To a degree, that's
where I come down.
It wasn't it wasn't overall a softball interview,
but there were moments that weren't so good.
Let's look at just a couple of moments.
Here is one question about whether Marjorie
Taylor GREENE has deliberately styled herself
after Donald Trump.
Speaker 2: How much have you styled yourself?
Speaker 1: And why don't we have audio here?
I'm not sure who is up.
We do have audio.
My head phone has become unplugged.
Let me plug that back in.
Beautiful.
All right.
Let's take it from the top.
Speaker 2: How much have you styled yourself
after Donald Trump?
Hmm.
People say.
Speaker 1: And by the way, this look from
Marjorie Taylor GREENE one thing I want to
say, and I won't harp on it, is Greene's attitude.
The entire interview was sort of of like,
this isn't a serious show.
Lesley Stahl isn't serious.
And I'm above this.
This is just me placating the fake news.
And it was pretty disgusting.
But let's not harp on that.
Speaker 2: That you are Trump in high heels.
I didn't intentionally style myself after
President Trump, but I can see how people
draw those similarities.
We both come from the same industry construction.
I also have pretty much a plain speaking style.
Yeah, and so does he.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So little bit fluffy, a little bit fluffy.
One of the better moments was when Lesley
Stahl was prepared with fact checks and tweets
and everything to question Marjorie Taylor
GREENE about things she had previously said,
including that the Parkland shooting was a
false flag and other things.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE basically just denies
it.
But I do think this was one of the stronger
parts of the interview.
Let's take a look.
Speaker 2: Shortly after she arrived in Washington,
the Democratic led House ousted her from her
committees because of her past endorsement
of violence against some Democratic leaders
and her history of embracing.
Q And on that, she explained in a speech on
the House floor, I stumbled across something,
and this was at the end of 2017 called.
Q And on that I was allowed to believe things
that weren't true, and that is absolutely
what I regret.
Well, I apologize to my colleagues.
I think apologies are important.
Okay.
Did you ever apologize to Nancy Pelosi about
the bullet to her head?
I didn't say that.
So I don't need to apologize.
Well, words that Didn't you like it?
Other people also ran my social media.
Speaker 1: So now it's like, listen, the party
of personal responsibility, that was other
people.
Well, if other people liked something about
Nancy Pelosi needs a bullet to the head and
you don't agree with it, shouldn't you loudly
denounce the sentiment?
I know other people run my social media.
Speaker 2: I don't think I did that.
Are you saying that you don't stand by what's
on your social media?
Well, of course I stand for what's on my social
media, but at times not.
You're not always in control.
We have all kinds of people that work on our.
Speaker 1: So it's not your fault.
Okay, Got it.
Well, great responsibility, huh?
Speaker 2: Social media.
Did you apologize for your position on Parkland,
Florida?
What was my position on Parkland, Florida?
That it was a false.
I don't know if you actually have my.
No, I never said Parkland was a false.
Speaker 1: Okay, So there is a post.
It's called The Payoff to Keep his Mouth Shut,
since it was a false flag planned shooting,
to which Marjorie Taylor GREENE responded.
Exactly.
Hmm.
Speaker 2: Oh, I've never said that school
shootings are horrible.
I don't think it's anything to joke about.
We fact checked before I got to this interview.
Have you fact checked all my statements from
kindergarten through 12th grade?
Speaker 1: Okay.
That's called a red herring.
Not not at issue.
She's denying having said things that are
on the record in college.
Speaker 2: And as I have paid my taxes and
never broken a law, and then I got a few speeding
tickets doing.
Speaker 1: It, remember, it doesn't have anything
to do with breaking the law.
It's she's denying, having said things that
she said, this is how you try to distract.
Speaker 2: Talk about those two, because I
think where you're going down is the same
attacks that people have attacked me with
over and over and over.
Speaker 1: She means holding me accountable
for things I've said.
Speaker 2: Well, if this is what you're known
for, I. I think it's good that you're responding
to the charges.
I think it's I think I think it's a legitimate
occurrence.
People for us to constantly focus on it, but
never focus on anything good about me.
Speaker 1: There is nothing good.
That's the problem.
I mean, it's a sad thing, but she's done nothing
good since coming to Congress.
She's only had this path of destruction where
she harasses the victims of school shootings,
spreads conspiracy theories, spreads medical
disinformation, and then she's never held
accountable for it.
So this is an attempt to ask her about the
things she's done, which are basically saying
horrible things.
Speaker 2: In Button this up and we'll move
on.
You want to bring the Republican Party closer
to your views.
You want to bring the country closer to your
views.
You've said that.
Okay.
Here are some of the things you've said that
America should have a Christian government,
that abortion should be banned nationally,
that you want to.
Defund the FBI.
Yes.
You want immigration to stop for four years?
You've said those things, correct?
Yeah.
These are these are some of my views.
The Constitution, the very First Amendment
prohibits having a religion in the government.
Yet the founding fathers quoted the Bible
constantly and were driven by their faith.
Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE That's a
total cop out, by the way.
Speaker 2: As a fervent supporter of the now
indicted Donald Trump.
She was a featured speaker at his rally in
Waco last weekend.
While she's adored here, the latest national
poll has her approval rating at just 29%.
Speaker 5: Marjorie Taylor GREENE You happen
to be here.
Would you like to run for the Senate?
No.
I'll fight like hell for you.
Speaker 2: The question for her and the country
is can she expand her brash MTG brand beyond
the right wing populist base?
Speaker 1: I believe the answer is obviously
not.
So listen, some fact checking.
There are certainly Marjorie Taylor GREENE
is a narcissist, much like Trump, and so you
never really get her because no matter how
you push her, eventually she'll say she's
being misquoted or you don't understand or
she's actually correct or whatever the case
may be.
One other moment I do want to show you from
this interview.
And I would I would watch the whole thing
if you really want to understand the full
scope of it, she said, actually, the government,
the U.S. government really isn't worthy of
much respect and deserves to be attacked.
Speaker 2: But also is often in attack mode.
And you appear to be.
Yes, I think.
But I think our government deserves it.
They don't really deserve to be respected
that much.
Speaker 1: Right.
And, of course, the government that doesn't
deserve much respect and deserves to be attacked
is the one that she works in and makes $175,000
a year for doing and is paid through the taxpayer
funded salaries of everyone.
That is in her position.
But it's it's an entity that should be attacked
and under the law.
So overall, this interview was an atrocity.
It was more an atrocity because of the things
that Marjorie Taylor GREENE said.
I don't think that there's some of you came
away from this saying this was a total puff
piece and it's horrible what Lesley Stahl
did.
Others came away saying it's amazing how Marjorie
Taylor GREENE was held accountable by Look
by Lesley Stahl.
I think that there were some really good attempts
to hold her accountable.
She's really slippery, like Trump is slippery,
and her base is not going to think twice about
supporting her based on this interview.
We all understand it for what it is.
So I don't know that damage was done, but
I don't know.
Let me put it this way.
I don't know that damage was done to Marjorie
Taylor Greene's reputation.
And I don't know that the interview was too
damaging to 60 Minutes.
My preference would have been not to have
her on there at all after seeing this interview.
I want to hear from you.
Let me know what you think.